(dramatic music)
- Yo, cuz, where'd you
get that jacket from?
(exasperated breathing)
- It's happened to you too?
- I even tried Tinder, Prima
but they're not good enough for them.
- Yessi, how could this
have happened to you?
What were you doing all year?
- I, I was single, and
happy.
(small scream)
- [Voiceover] Yessica.
- Yessi, isn't he so cute?
- He rescued a poodle and named it Chuchi.
(giggling)
- [Voiceover] It's happened to you too?
- [Voiceover] I even tried Tinder, Prima,
but they're not good enough for them.
- [Voiceover] What were
you doing all year?
(sinister laughter)
- Yessi?
Yessi.
(dramatic music)
- Hey! Sorry I'm late, guys.
This is my boyfriend, Steven.
- Hola, everybody.
- It's here. It's here.
- [All] It's here!
- It's here.
- [All] It's here.
- Get it.
- There.
- I think they got it.
- Yeah, you get it.
- It's here.